you
I believe this is the first time we are
playing and 28 was the magic number and
my opponent is the one who guessed it
let's try the Sicilian wine up and let's
go with this most times I would play
this version of cough but I've been
going into this stuff recently and this
is if you want to be more aggressive as
black you block with the night on d7 not
so familiar with that so I'm gonna go
with this one
and recapture with my queen my nights
ideal placement is here and I want to
make sure I'm in a position to me d4
with establishing upon on d5 so how can
I make that happen I think this is an
okay start Knight f6 if pawn push I take
Knight recaptures I side step top now
maybe that is a little bit annoying
what am I talking about how am I talking
about this I hang on a second I could do
this first what was I talking about if
this move is played I want to make sure
I could establish the pawn on d5 that's
if white goes forward with a c3 d4 plan
if white is saying you know what I'm not
going to allow any imbalance in the
center then if white says I'm not going
to allow an imbalance in the center and
place c3 d4 ideas then I want to make
sure I could establish a pawn on d5 and
stop those white pawns from rolling and
rolling me over but we're not having
that d3 is a much tamer approach and I
think I want to go with kingside
fianchetto
you know this diagonal looks quite
appealing let's go for that so how will
Y open up the position is a question
that I have because if it's not d4 is it
going to come in the form of f4 you're
going to come in in the form of e 5
where will be where will there be an
exchange of pawns is my number one
question it's going to be quite
difficult I could tell you this it's
going to be quite difficult to get an e5
and d f-- d4 since I have both Bishop 2
ponds and Knight focused on that now if
i play my but night out here there is an
opportunity for this advance but i'm not
afraid of that that could happen but i
think I'm still in a quite alright
position I guess there was maybe some
fear of a knight coat coming here this
seems a little bit awkward and to be a
waste of time the h3 move I can see it
if maybe you're fearful of a Bishop g4
move I can't wrap my head around why
each three is played I guess more long
term for a flight square let's go here
c4 is a very soft point if this pond
decides to advance for one thing white
has lost time I could say that much
since he previously moved to d3 d4 is a
jumping point now can't be kicked as
easily
this Knight would have to move first how
do I make progress get all my pieces
working he's not doing anything just yet
uh you know what I want to do
I don't know if I like my Queens
placement
hmm
I don't know what kind of a plan I
should go forward with night here takes
takes these doubled pawns not I don't
know if I want to do that let's go here
I'm not sure why man I don't know why
Queen here I guess some now it wasn't
really to play here I'm not I can't I
don't know why I did that move I don't
know why I guess I guess ok e5 it it
stops white from going forward with this
now that was that wasn't even a threat
with my queen on d7 all right okay night
here this was my thought I knew I had a
reason I was just having trouble
recalling it Knight d7 I wanted to
vacate this square for the night so he
could jump around a little bit I want to
exchange off another pair of pieces
another pair of minor pieces so 97 to e5
okay they're nights running away where
is he going
let's throw my knight in the center
those two nights were counterparts so
when one of them moves I want one of the
things I look into almost immediately is
can I move my other one and do something
exciting and I could I could jump in the
center right now this Knight move here
would have been interesting
let's do that I'm fearful of this night
move actually it might be quite good or
no you know probably now I think I have
a good response in the center right here
I take pawn takes although this files
open up I have this d5 break in my
pieces come to life my knight in
particular hitting the bishop and this
guy but what do I do if Bishop takes
pawn takes Knight here I think I would
have been losing a pawn with that
variation let's go forward with this
this is a good position for white this
is not fun
it's um yeah it's definitely not fun to
be in a position where your Queen has to
babysit upon I guarantee that is not a
fun thing
he's may be accessible though Queen d7
to b4 how do you defend this the knight
has to go here about even on time and
I'm not happy with how I played this
position with this team approach my
white D 3 and E 4 it seemed like I
should have been doing something
different I guess he's gonna fall I
guess he's just a dead duck so if he's
gonna fall I'm gonna get him returned
yeah I better take him so there goes the
a pawn the rooks are still very active
take that I worked myself into a pin my
Queen runs the risk of maybe getting
trapped one day rook here night here
exploiting the pin now she could move
along the 6th rank these rooks are way
too active way too active maybe I could
trade a bunch look here
chop-chop-chop-chop I think that's good
I need to get rid of no no no rook here
Knight here is played
what am i doing there that is the
biggest nothing move ever that is the
biggest nothing move ever age five I
guess it is clamping down one day with
age four
that was definitely I don't know what to
do
move let's just make a pond move
when in doubt move your H pond that's
what I said
moments before I pulled the trigger on
that move 35 seconds to 45 ten-second
edge this night is a rock he's a rock
that could be defended I'm breaking the
pin and defending that's very important
otherwise I could continually get
hammered all right I'm just I'm over
peace here Queen takes pawn should have
played here it's more active let's just
drop all the way back he takes pawn his
own okay they're just down on time don't
untie all right a good game let's go
back because I don't know there's got to
be a better way to go about things for
both of us let's see all right we have
this exchange keep in mind that this is
a possibility c3 d4
and also c4 if you're looking for a game
to reference and by the way there's the
game between Carlsen and Anand that you
can check out
I think it's from the 2012 chess masters
final in Bilbao I'm not mistaken
c4 d4 and you could maybe use that game
as a reference for a particular plan
white goes forward with DD 3 has to be a
bit atypical because we didn't even have
any opening and opening up of the
position maybe here's something better I
could be looking into how about trying
to expand a bit more in this center B 5
B 4 maybe that's something I could be
looking into on my end and on your end I
think you could do one better to do
without h3 and also consider the plain
of c4 c4 and D for the Marazzi bind type
of formation or at least get d4 in if
you're not going to have the C pawn play
if this d4 break in however I don't
believe that black has any problems if
you if you just have this pond still on
its home square on c2 so I think having
him contribute you work your your pawns
on light squares would be coordinated
well with your remaining dark squared
bishop so you can look into that c4 d4
c3 d4 or at the very least d4 that's the
recurring move
turns out that your night becomes very
strong and I think what's better than
night b5 is to take my night and after I
recapture to play here and I'm losing
upon how about maybe there's some tactic
Bishop takes Knight pawn takes Knight b5
Queen b7 and if Knight takes here now
Knight takes met by rook takes then
maybe there's a fork or something I
don't know it gets messy but this is
certainly a variation to consider to
take the knight fresh and then jump into
b5 with the fork on Queen and two pawns
we didn't really get there did we
nope but your knight let me go back
actually your knight turned out to be
fantastic dropping into b5 you had a
really strong light-square grip and I
didn't have any lights great control my
pawns are on dark squares I wonder if I
could have been considering something
like e 6 and d5 at this point to make
sure that this night will be removed
from c4 maybe I was too quick to play d5
because now your knight is there to stay
he's a monster way too annoying anyhow
alright good game Louis 691
you